entire industry is at a Crossroads and
everybody knows it the the the the what
the financial motor uh has to be
completely redefined and there is some
degree of pie here that is going to have
to be equitably distributed by the
people who are responsible for the
content not the folks who make the deals
for the content the folks will actually
make it and first up is the writers we
do not have scripts without writers it
all starts with the written word and up
up next is the directors we do not have
film stories without directors and the
actors are coming up as well so there is
going to have to be some sort of sit
down and for the common good of the
story The Arts and Sciences and The
Business of show yes uh like minds are
going to have to come down and and be
Equitable and we all believe it or not
some some type of win-win situation yes
we all hope this doesn't last long